it's britain's second busiest
cross-channel port every year a quarter
of a million lorries pass through
portsmouth carrying goods to and from
europe to continue doing so they were
told to build a 25 million pound border
control center to carry out the
government's new post-brexit checks on
imports which were due to begin this
month the lorries come in with the meat
and poultry from there the goods are
taken to the freezers and then to the
inspection rooms
but two months ago the government
announced the new checks will be put on
hold until at least the end of next year
and with a review looking at creating a
digital border for most goods in future
this facility may never actually be
needed while the government paid out 17
million pounds towards the cost the
council which owns the port had to
borrow the remaining 7.8 million and
it's an ongoing drain on resources it's
costing a million pounds a year to run
that was meant to be funded by the
people using it now the government says
nobody needs to use it how am i meant to
find a million pounds from that it'll
have to come from council taxpayers here
in portsmouth so your message to
government is if they don't compensate
you then you will take legal action yes
absolutely and it is down to the
government to sort out this mess
this border control post was designed to
inspect 50 000 lorry loads of goods a
year physical spot checks on animal and
plant products meat fish vegetables
fruit and timber but portsmouth isn't
the only one facilities like this one
have been built all over the country and
they're all currently standing empty
altogether 41 border control posts have
been set up at ports railway stations
and airports the government gave out 200
million pounds in grants to help pay but
the funding was massively oversubscribed
so the ports themselves also paid around
100 million to get the work done
the government claimed the decision not
to impose the new controls this year
will save traders up to 1 billion pounds
and help with the cost of living
importers are delighted the fewer
constraints and hoops that we have to
jump through and hurdles that we have to
jump over
basically mean that we have less cost
if we have less cost then we can pass
that on to our
customer base but the british sports
association say it's all been a huge
waste of money if they'd decided this
two three years ago that we're going to
have no
checks and controls or limited targeted
processes at our borders then we
wouldn't have had to go to all the
effort and expense of building such
facilities and while talks between the
ports and the government continue for
now these gates are locked firmly shut
amanda aircast sky news portsmouth